franchement est-ce que c'est le moment
nous avons
collectivement nous n'avons pas voté
l'instauration d'une taxe sur les super
profits pour montrer un vrai pas en
avant sur la solidarité
vous n'avez pas non plus voté le smic à
1500 euros une vraie revalorisation des
salaires à la hauteur de l'inflation pas
non plus des minima sociaux
tu aurait permis de donner des revenus
pérennes et de revaloriser la valeur
travail est là est ce que le but c'est
de donner 150 euros en plus aux
travailleurs pauvres ou de priver les
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux 200
euros à la rentrée scolaire en réalité
l'objectif c'est d'opposer les
travailleurs pauvres aux bénéficiaires
du rsa le sous amendement de philippe
pouillé montre bien qu'il ya un vrai
problème parce que tout de tout d'un
coup il faut sauver les bénéficiaires de
la hache de ces privations de 100 euros
à la rentrée nous avons demandé un
scrutin public mais nous préférerions
que cet amendement soit retiré tout
simplement
[Musique]